Écrire une lettre postale à l'ancienne sur un papier avec un crayon,
C'est vraiment un petit plaisir que j'ai retrouvé.
FAUX !
En fait j'ai eu un petit problème avec ma banque,
alors je les ai appelés,
et la dame au téléphone elle m'a dit:
*voix au téléphone*: Pour cette demande il faut nous envoyer un courrier postal, par la poste
Alors je me suis mis à écrire cette lettre
Et au bout de quelques lignes j'ai redécouvert un problème que j'avais en CE2,
alors que j'ai 24 ans...
L'écriture penchée !
Putain, c'est ridicule, ce truc. J'ai 24 ans et j'écris encore penché.
Heureusement que je passe pas un entretien d'embauche.
Alors je sors d'une école d'ingénieur,
je suis trilingue,
professionnel et extrêmement motivé
Voici ma lettre de motivation. Homme ridicule !
Du coup, j'ai dû tracer des lignes avec une règle au crayon pour écrire.
Mais bon après je les ai gommées
Je suis pas complètement fou non plus
Il y a aussi un truc que j'avais oublié,
maintenant que j'ai l'habitude d'envoyer des emails, des textos, et autres tweets,
de manière parfaitement illimitée
c'est que, pour envoyer une lettre postale extrêmement ringarde qui va mettre trois jours à arriver, il faut payer !
What is the fuck ?
Nos parents, à l'époque, il devait dépenser trop de thune
Pour la fête de samedi soir,
je ne sais pas encore si je peux venir.
Ecoute, je te confirme ça par lettre
OK? On fait comme ça?
Ça marche.
Ah non, j'ai plus de crédit
Donc, j'ai dû aller acheter un timbre
Et y'a un truc que j'ai toujours trouvé hyper dégueulasse avec les timbres
C'est que, un timbre, à part la poste,
tu peux l'acheter que dans les vieux PMU
vraiment crado
et la partie non protégée du timbre
il faut tout simplement la lécher
Alors, si personne ne me regarde, moi, je fais la technique du doigt
Comme ça j'ai pas trop trop de maladies
du PMU
Et enfin, après avoir bien galéré quand j'arrive devant la boître aux lettres pour poster la lettre
J'ai l'impression de devenir plutôt débile
et d'hésiter pendant 40, 50 secondes
mais après avoir autant galéré, j'ai pas envie de me tromper de trou si tu veux
suite à quoi, je développe une sorte de parano
qui me dit que, si ça se trouve, la lettre elle est pas bien tombée
Alors que, normalement, c'est trou...
classique.
Je ne sais pas si je suis le seul à galérer pour envoyer une lettre de merde,
mais en tout cas vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux sur la page Facebook "Norman fait des vidéos"
et ça, ça me fait super plaisir
Partagez cette vidéo sur Facebook si vous voulez
D'accord?
Au fait, si tout d'un coup vous voulez vous la péter et prendre un stylo plume pour écrire votre lettre
Ça fait partie des choses qui sont des mauvaises idées
Mauvaises idée
Han ! Si tu souffles dans l'ballon t'es mort
Si t'accélères ils pourront p't-être pas t'rattraper
Mauvaise idée!
T'as l'impression qu'ta p'tite copine veut s'barrer
Tu cherches à lui faire un enfant pour la garder
Mauvaise idée
Tu veux faire marrer ton beau-père
Tu fais des allusions sur la nuit dans sa fille que t'as passée
Mauvaise idée !
Commencer la clope à trente ans
Les mélanges d'alcools différents
Haha !